I have a feeling you were gonna pick a
lot of desserts for our meal what this
looks different and that's what it's
like parenting a toddler hi I'm Hannah
and I'm the world okay it's mom now real
time in our house is usually planned by
me which means there is a lot of variety
so I want to try something new I'm gonna
let my kids meal plan every meal of an
entire week now this is something that
you guys have been asking for for months
so I'm going all-in I'm gonna give it a
try I hope you appreciate it and please
wish us luck so the rules are there are
no rules well no there has to be one
rule because my kids are very weird and
for one meal they might be like we're
gonna eat grass so it has to be food but
if they want to eat McDonald's for all
three meals in a day and top it off with
an ice cream sundae
this is their week we are going to try
something really new this week what is
it what do you think it is
we can't go potty probably we're going
to let you guys pick everything we eat
for a whole week turn off the table dude
I don't think my kids are deprived of
treats and like special foods and meals
but it's definitely not the norm this
will be their week to just go completely
rogue Monday Tuesday mac and cheese oh
my god Thursday while that we could eat
this
sushi I think we got a good menu guys
let's go the grocery store shopping for
the groceries wasn't difficult per se
because everything was very detailed in
these meal plans but it was pretty
expensive I was really surprised by how
expensive some of the junk food is I'd
always thought it was cheaper but it
actually ended up costing a lot more
another big factor in the cost was
usually when I'm grocery shopping for
the week I plan our meals around what's
on sale I shot very smart my kids did
not give me that option with this meal
plan happy Monday everyone it is day one
of kids meal planning this week and here
is today's month yeah go ahead
here's today's menu breakfast cold pizza
lunch cheese sandwich and french fries
cheese sandwich in kids speak of world
cheese sandwich dinner ham sandwiches
she's pasta and for dessert ice cream
yeah
healthy start moving off right with some
cold pizza I make this last night and
refrigerated it which felt weird but I
look cold pizza do you yeah I'm gonna be
real and admit that that it's not the
first time we've had pizza for breakfast
makes me hope of human that doesn't make
me a Padma these are all foods that I
like you want to serve them fresh and
warm so I would never pack these in a
lunch because I feel like they'll pack
kind of soggy or maybe not ideal plus I
usually don't make lunches that take
this much time and have this much
cooking involved huh
so dinner organic mixed veggies makes me
feel good in my momma heart I'm a
the mistake of asking the boys what goes
on the ham sandwich my kids definition
of a ham sandwich is ham on bread no
condiments no toppings no nothing
I like fully loaded sandwiches I am
Subway's worst nightmare more olives get
it in there
that sandwich was bad I like my
sandwiches like I like my men dry they
were very very pleased after day one and
now I'm just realizing that why it tried
so hard to write ice cream and I forgot
just day two Tuesday's menu breakfast
grilled corn and pasta lunch lettuce
sandwich and strawberries dinner
mac and cheese and Doritos morning
breakfast grilled corn and pasta and of
course I made spaghetti because it's the
best pasta in the world and a pasta that
matters this look at different it's what
you picked this good for the morning
[Music]
typical mornings at our house are very
rushed
breakfast is usually cereal so something
like grilled corn is not really doable
for us but luckily Matt decided to be a
hero got up at 6:30 and started grilling
some corn so I could boil some pasta
what goes in a lettuce sandwich man
Asian mustard anything else
no I realized I've been putting too much
effort into their lunches every day I'll
make a sandwich and I'm like getting all
the garnishes and really loading it up
when in reality they just want a hunka
lettuce on some bread time to ease up on
myself a little bit with the lunches
dinner
Doritos and mac and cheese they are
thrilled I have a feeling the boys are
gonna eat every bite I
could not be looking forward to this
dinner less hope they didn't hear me
phone app the cheese kid how do you feel
about this oh so good you never get
these huh phone at the tea I'm happy
I cooked for you amazing get it oh it's
like a college kids dinner Oh
gourmet oh thank you and literally all I
wanted at this point was a piece of
broccoli but it's so like something to
know about this meal is not only was it
why it's favorite meal of the week it
was also Matt it was real people food it
just wasn't it wasn't grown-up food
Wednesday breakfast watermelon and
blackberries thank goodness
lunch talked about dinner
McDonald's dessert root beer flop blow
and white rice
Wednesday morning breakfast it's fruit
yeah yeah yeah oh my god get out of here
with that thing huh look at that
I could eat this all day you found your
glasses
all right here oh great I'm glad you did
oh and you found my underwear it's new
guys it's not dirty okay
Taco Bell for lunch was a tricky one
because not like I can just go grab in
fast food and drop it off at school at
lunchtime I have to pack it first thing
in the morning so what we ended up
having to do was pick up Taco Bell the
evening before refrigerate it and put it
in their lunches cold
there's nothing worse than reheated fast
food in my opinion so I'm not looking
forward to it but maybe this will make
them pick something healthier or like
change their mind from all the fast food
this week how did you enjoy your Taco
Bell lunch it was so good you really are
you excited about the dinner we're in
the desert
oh my gosh I don't know about desert
guys we've been eating pretty crap
lately I felt my digestive system
screeching to a halt at this point the
kids were fine
my old was feeling it the boys picked
grouper floats for dessert they insisted
on buying sour patch kids ice cream in
root beer this looks so gross call me an
old lady but a root beer float should be
vanilla yeah it wasn't good mmm
by Thursday my body was starting to
reject this food breakfast waffles and
toppings and juice lunch sushi and
cheese dinner fries and cheeseburgers
and berries Thursday morning breakfast
what do you have Wyatt it's a lot for
weight room and shattering yep and
yogurt there's a promotion that says
[Music]
one thing I noticed on the menu is the
kids did not designate any drinks so I
decided that the drinks were how I was
going to sneak in as many veggies as
possible
that's one tried-and-true way that I get
vegetables into my kids dude can you eat
normally oh my god what just happened
lunch was another tricky thing to pack I
know getting California rolls because
the crab in there is cooked and I feel
like that's less health hazardous
because I don't really know the protocol
of packing sushi and a lunch
the wild card really was cheese does it
go on the sushi or does it just I
scooped the wasabi out so when you fly
all over the rolls
my kids eat sushi yeah I feel like that
is that not normal
maybe it's a California kid thing I
didn't put cheese on my sushi I ate
cheese alongside my sushi chose lunch
for you good so tonight's dinner is on
the menu burgers the fries and
blueberries well why didn't outfit
change for dinner look how fancy he
looks don't put that in your mouth you
can't commit okay are you excited
ha how do you feel so excited I am
actually okay with this because jokes on
the kids I went I got vegetarian burgers
because this menu has a lot of red meat
in it for us they didn't say what kind
of burger it had to be so beyond burgers
it is I don't think anybody noticed that
they weren't real meat Matt never knows
I've been doing this to Matt for years
secret's out sorry Matt I care about
your health Friday was a special day
Friday's menu breakfast beans and rice
and almond milk lunch
peanut butter and jelly chips apple
sauce and juice
dinner was a surprised return of a
family favorite meal beans rice and
almond milk well eat your beans and rice
are you stoked Jackson so you pray this
is not another breakfast one some
countries this is a normal breakfast do
you like when mommy sometimes claims the
menu I wish you did Allah when I was
pregnant with both kids all I ate was
refried beans cheese and jalapenos that
was every meal so I'm happy
lunch was normal I got to make TV and
J's in the morning it was so easy oh my
god
I missed that can you guess what
tonight's dinner is only oh gee mommy
Progress fans will know spaghetti like
iconic it's such a fun food good you
like this yeah do you like it sorry so
Friday was a good day
by Saturday I would kill for something
green on the menu and I definitely found
my chance
Saturday's menu was breakfast Starbucks
lunch burrito bowls and smoothies and
dinner ramens one thing to note about
Saturday is every single meal is takeout
which is convenient but it's also very
expensive
not something we can do very regularly
Saturday morning and it's Starbucks
today and I love Starbucks more than
anything fun fact I actually used to
work there and I loved it it was one of
my favorite jobs ever so I am so loyal
to Starbucks this is not sponsored I
just I love them sponsor me please what
are you gonna order I'm
get hot tea and a breakfast sandwich
what voice is that mad don't know what
are you gonna get baby
[Music]
Bettina look at you such an LA socialite
is your latte got you something new
what's this
it's a biscuit it's not caffeinated
lunch with the burrito bowls and
smoothies I seize that opportunity to
shove a bunch of greens into my children
and I took it hey psyche you wanted this
I'm making a smoothie to go along with
lunch and I honestly can't take it
anymore so don't tell the kids I'm
loading the smoothie up with blueberries
beets strawberries banana a bunch of
spinach while yogurt and almond milk I
could drink this whole thing best thing
I've had all week dinner was ramen I'm
not even hungry but they were gonna eat
it I might have a little bit how's the
taste Jackson you hungry oh I get it
Sunday last day going out with a bang
here breakfast cereal with whipped cream
lunch hamburger and pickles dinner ribs
chicken Caesar salad and fried sushi you
know normal good morning everybody I
feel like you guys live with us now
because you are here for every meal
what's for breakfast this morning or
capture
Oh whip cream on here mmm it's a good
dessert so lunch another hamburger what
a whoop-dee-doo
we ended up getting fast food again
which at this point I was like whatever
just pile it on just to throw it at me
just put it in my mouth I don't care for
today's dinner of the grand finale I
think the boys chose an epic thief I'm
going to start with the ribs they take
about six hours and we smoke them if
there's one thing I can say with full
certainty I'm really good at its making
ribs it's a three to one method three
hours in uncovered two hours in covered
one hour uncovered and it's basically
foolproof when we compiled kind of
everything we were gonna make we
realized that it was just too much food
for all of us to finish so we mix the
fried sushi they're picking the meals
but they're not wasting food not on my
watch
I can't wait to eat a new look but
that's because when you smoke it you get
pink on the outside look at these bones
I couldn't keep the ribs on the bones
pretty proud I know for like competition
ribs you want them to stay on the bone
but it's just family ribs no I'm very
excited is this your favorite meal of
the week mine too
what I learned from this week is my kids
like most kids don't have a firm grasp
on nutrition and don't really care that
much which is totally fair so that being
said I would not try this for a whole
week ever again I would do it for a day
maybe it's like a birthday treat they
really had a fun time planning the menu
with me and going grocery shopping for
everything I think a week was just a lot
so that's what I got for today I'm
Hannah and have you tried this would you
try this let me know in the comments let
me know how it went or if you have any
ideas for future food challenges for my
family let me know in the comments as
well now if you'll please excuse me I'm
going to be prepping fruit for my
lunches
for the next five years till next time
[Music]